[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from a horse and buggy tour and
beautiful Central Park why because chili
Klaus
is back in town chili Klaus my old
friend it's good to see you but not good
to see you too so for those who aren't
familiar with chili Klaus and if you're
a hot ones fan and you don't know who
chili Klaus is shame on you he's the
chili God and Denmark he tours the world
and he feeds guests hot chilies a show
that's borderline tortures has guests
more than even we do yeah but we should
enjoying the chili pepper it's like
that's all in John I saw you on Top Gear
yeah and it's been a huge year since
last time we caught up what's been going
on with you man had a lot of things
really I did the video with top gear so
we shoot it in Norway it was crazy and I
couldn't get a word out of the steak you
couldn't you're alright thank you so
mystery yeah he's still a mystery did
you ever feel sometimes like me where
you're like oh I ended up and this is my
thing and maybe I have to do this
forever and there's no escaping it and
there's no getting out of it do you ever
have that feeling every time you did you
really hooked up in exactly what you're
talking about like maybe we should have
just done a brain freeze interview
series I something Jeff you would have
started eating a between apples really
yeah
[Music]
so here's something that I have to get
better at I don't do anything to prepare
and I don't do anything afterwards what
do you do before the interview to
prepare yourself and what do you do
afterwards to recover before I drink a
little bit of milk just to you know to
cook yeah code my my stomach and
afterwards I find the couch and sit
still and thing a little bit about my
life
I didn't bring some snacks with this
your little some snacks it's perfect
yeah where these are from maybe they are
from smoking it they are from smoking ad
where else do you get something like
this other than pucker but pepper
company.com yeah and in typical IDI
fashion he did not send us any
information on these peppers today I'm
very exciting at this with all this view
in Central Park with the horse and I've
never tried anything like this before us
race you guys so I guess I'll lose the
sunglasses now because this is like go
time all right so here's our unboxing
let's see what we got here oh whoa
so these ones these red ones I know are
the Carolina Reaper yeah there they are
the camera I used to look at them look
at the teeny they have really really
hard
I think these papers here are the
telling fitness maybe and they are very
spicy and this one I think they are
having kind of things chocolate happen
here or something but look at these with
the tail so racy these are the Carolina
Reapers the world's hottest pepper and
then we got them from smoking add curry
yeah wrap octopod yeah and he's the
world record holder so we got not only
the world's hottest pepper but we got it
straight from the record holding farm
yes is a Frankenstein version of a
Carolina Reaper and we're about to eat
these but don't do this at home this is
what the stupid yeah exactly that you
could do this is so stupid
yeah we're idiots
I don't even know if we're gonna live
through this it's going down let's go
back cheers Wow
this is where we are
hi
all right hey you doing already good
pretty good
Hey look chilly clouds I think that's
where they shot you got mail Wow I think
I also got me hot maybe what do you
think in New York City
yes I hope City beautiful city this is
crazy I hate how I remember last time I
was here I couldn't even speak but the
flavor is fantastic it's Rudy it's Rudy
it's like hey hot apple or something oh
it's my neck yeah around my side of my
face oh and now my arms start shear it
Oh
I see beautiful side yeah Central Park
Karen Wimmer is different definitely one
of the hottest pepper from the pennant
why did I do this again
whoa what do you think Shawn
nope I think what happened was it
happened so long this is very hard I
think it's a little bit hot that I
Scandinavian cousins ah I got cocky
hmm I got cocky just like oh we could
just do it again oh oh and I can't since
my arms ah
uh-oh this is quickly oh I didn't
remember their Soros it's this way
harder than Irma we are we are sure I
love your program first we feast
ladies and gentlemen check out to short
run again
Wow
and before we go shout out to chili
Klaus
the greatest in the world the best has
ever done it oh what a hole what am I
[Music]